[Music]
i donated to biden which i did
i supported kamala harris from day one
which i did
i i even starred in
[Music]
biden's victory video america the
beautiful
i was in it
i did more in the 2020 election to
to actively work for someone's campaign
i did more than i've ever done in my
entire life for any candidate whatsoever
and i'm disgusted i said and i said a
year in i'm discussing with them both
i'm discussing with kamala harris and
joe biden
i have been a
consistent democratic voter
for 16 years
i voted for biden thinking that he was a
safe thinking that he was the safest
choice
before i voted but before i started
supporting biden
i was a kamala harris supporter
but
but biden i'm furious
theory is that what do i
not like
about
the bible administration well
uh
day one
day one
biden turned title seven and title nine
inside out
if you wanna know why you have leah
thomas
that man swimming in uh
competing against women in in swimming
competitions that's why
gender identity
if i had known biden was this much of a
genderist
there's no
way i would have voted for that man
no way
i am upset about the afghanistan
withdrawal the video of
refugees dropping from c-117 teams
uh to their deaths will haunt this
presidency and will haunt this country
for decades to come i don't like
critical race theory
critical race theory is a trojan horse
that has a lot of darker elements hiding
inside like the diversity equity and
inclusion movement
i don't like the idea
of
kids
black kids white kids whatever separated
by race and then made to feel
like
one group is oppressed and the other
group is not i don't like where we are
now
with
covid
masks don't work cd theme has said zbp
said so in may of 2020.
omicron is a weak variant everyone knows
that
and you're still trying to enforce this
kind of stuff on people why
why who's benefiting from this
i am seeing the democratic party i've
seen my party headed into the wrong
direction i am seeing joe biden going
into going into these dark realms making
all of this stuff all of this stuff that
has no place in schools that has no
place in society
that is how the party destroys itself
that is how liberals become so
so far over to the left that they become
completely unrecognizable from what they
used to be
i don't recognize where we're at anymore
and i'm pissed about it
democrats i need you to listen to me
carefully
the fact that i a registered democrat
am appearing on fox news i don't have a
grift i don't have a thing i don't have
a gimmick i don't have a brand and the
fact that i a blue-collar democratic
worker
and speaking to fox news should scare
you and scare the rest of our party
the fact that they're willing to talk to
me and msnbc and cnn are not
that is a problem and that should tell
you all how far we've fallen away from
the common man